queria fazer uma nota rápida antes de
começarmos com disse cristina em algumas
cadeiras colocamos umas folhas brancas
já três como esta
por isso os casos que tiverem as folhas
queria só pedir vos prass guardarem até
o final não nos mandem fora vamos usá
los mais tarde com uma experiência
também
e hoje quero quebrar o mito de que o
trabalho do matemático o engenheiro não
é tão criativo como músico e vice-versa
com o pintor o bailarino não é tão
estruturado no seu raciocínio como
programador existe aquela idéia de que
trabalhar com números é algo mecânico
competitivo e como usar materiais ou
escrever um livro são atividades que
mais facilmente libertar a criatividade
hoje quer mostrar que não é
necessariamente verdade vamos ver um
exemplo desta peça de dança
contemporânea
o teste cego bailarino um sistema vivo
cada palavra sem regras
por um lado elas são atraídas pelo corpo
do bailarino e por outro são afastadas
da gestante palavras o comportamento do
teste é parte integrante do espetáculo o
valor indústria com as palavras e estas
respondem a dança em tempo real
para por exemplo como agora valem vai
ser obrigado a dar um passo em frente
para apanhar todas as palavras nesta
semana
nesta peça o valor eo encontrou uma
linguagem de expressão
brincando experimentando com o sistema
de regras
apesar de serem simples em canecas
conseguem criar comportamento complexo
permitindo criar uma coreografia própria
só faz sentido nesta simbiose interativa
com o computador
eu quero mostrar a criatividade pode
fugir quando temos essas regras fini um
espaço de possibilidades e quando
aprendemos a brincar com elas pelo que
nem vamos descobrir que o computador nos
pode ajudar a fazer essa união entre o
pensamento criativo eo pensamento
estruturado
quando era criança gostava de ver as
coisas a mexer por exemplo ver aquelas
sementes quando ainda estavam se
conhecendo e coptos disse que no caso
das formigas descobriram que a mim com
curso d'água vai tomar porque todos os
objetos têm comportamentos tão diferente
e interessante
hoje todos temas infantis e esta
continua a ser a pergunta que mais me
intriga porque todos estes objetos têm
comportamentos tão diferentes entre os
antis
para tentar responder esta pergunta
podemos criar a entidade que imitam
estes comportamentos
no entanto com tentando imitar a
inteligência a um problema um sistema
inteligente tem esta capacidade de nos
surpreender
constantemente inventar novas funções de
ser criativo um sistema inteligente é
publicidade criativo mas eu não gosto de
pensar que a criatividade vem do nada de
pensar que existem oportunidades para
sermos criativos
por exemplo quando nos dão uma folha em
branco em dizem algo do gênero fazer uma
coisa espetacular o que quiser
surpreendem
é normal ficar bloqueado sem saber por
onde começar
por outro lado vejo o que acontece
quando damos uma caixa de lego uma
criança
cada peça de lego tem uma forma e cor
definida em um encaixe específico
muitas vezes nem temos as peças todas
precisávamos para construir o que
queremos
no entanto ao manipularmos as peças
tentando encaixar umas nas outras
vamos ter de idéias vamos pensando em
maneiras de resolver o problema
de repente há tantas coisas que se
conseguem fazer com legos essência do
computador é seguir uma seqüência de
regras tal como os legos
vamos combinar estas regras seguinte
forma de encaixe específicos mostrar que
é igualmente fácil criar um
comportamento complexo com o computador
quero mostrar outro exemplo
começamos com esta imagem um ponto azul
no marco pontos brancos ea regra é muito
muito simples quando um ponto branco
está a tocar em um mas apenas um ponto
azul
esse ponto passa a ser usou é só isto é
a única regra mas quando aplicamos
novamente à regra
descobrimos que nem todos os pontos
creche da mesma maneira há pontos
brancos que ficavam em dois pontos azuis
e por isso continuarão brancos
o que será que vai acontecer quando
evoluirmos esta regra o que vemos é
conseguirmos esta regra conseguimos
criar limitar o crescimento de
estruturas complexas são familiares são
os flocos de neve e apenas uma regra
essência do computador é seguir uma
seqüência de regras mas agora
descobrimos que mesmo com regras simples
conseguimos criar comportamento que
consideramos complexo e bel ou seja
comportamento mesmo que siga regras
mecânicas e repetitivas
não quer dizer que seja previsível mas
quero agora falar vos o segundo
ingrediente para a criatividade que
vemos nos lagos brincar
brincar é importante porque quando
brincamos não temos medo de tentar
idéias e sempre tentamos idéias já
tentamos encontrar coisas novas mas o
mundo real as escolhas que fazemos tem
implicações
devemos criar alguma coisa tem que
investir muito tempo ficaram muito
esforço e muitas vezes é difícil mudar o
que criamos é um grande compromisso com
o processo ficou o resultado final e por
isso muitas vezes não brincamos
mas curiosamente o computador parece
conseguir fugir
este compromisso nós já estamos
habituados a usar a mesma máquina nosso
telemóvel a portátil para desenhar a
trocar mensagens para o irs sobre a
previsão do tempo para assinar não não é
estranho computador parece um camaleão e
mesma máquina nespresso que instalamos
uma aplicação e fica tudo diferente do
computador é conhecido regras mas
podemos mudar livremente a seqüência o
computador deixa de brincar com estas
regras criariam apresentar com elas
brincaram com o comportamento das coisas
são os programas corremos no computador
assim tão fácil
estamos todos a programar como é que
criam os mesmos programas
pode parecer estranho mas tal com uma
aplicações para escrever documentos
também aplicações para escrever
programas mas este é um exemplo de uma
das linguagens que os programadores usam
pra escrever programas realmente não
parece nada fácil já que tanta coisa
ficam os prédios muito facilmente
mas o que é curioso no computador é que
também nos deixa e não ficar presentes
linguagens podemos inventar novas formas
programar
quero mostrar vos um exemplo esta é uma
linguagem de programação visual que tem
vindo a desenvolver nesta linguagem de
programação desenhamos programas através
de nós
essas bolinhas brigam entre si para
trocar informação
esse esquema é um programa por exemplo
neste caso o primeiro nos apresenta uma
câmera de vídeo esta câmera temos aqui
montada e o segundo as imagens que
chegam dessa câmera
este esquema se conhecer regras como
vinha falando vamos começar a cultura
maconha
as imagens que nos chegam da câmera só
vocês e vamos tentar fazer alguma coisa
interessante com esta linguagem vamos
construir um instrumento musical fazer
isto para fazer funcionar este
instrumento quer usar o nosso movimento
então vamos fazer pra isso e vou ligar
mais um nó
aqui no nosso programa que vai receber
essas imagens e calcular as diferenças
ao longo do tempo
com mais esta regra se conhecia o que
temos agora uma nova imagem que lhes
disse honda movimento na sala agora o
que queremos fazer é e queremos fazer
agora é juntar todo este movimento
num número para termos a quantidade
total do movimento na sala
com mais esta regra obtemos um gráfico
que nos diz
o valor deste número apenas fazemos
príncipe pretende mexer muito
vamos ver com o número aumenta bastante
e se baixarem diminui então agora única
coisa que falta é ligar a este número um
gerador de som vê lo green pode ser
muito alto mas despencaram 11 e já está
vamos com um protótipo do nosso
instrumento musical
tal como os que existem outras
linguagens visuais e textuais que
podemos usar para ter vários estilos
falar com o computador não tem que ser
sempre a mesma coisa ao mosquito com
mais ou menos chama nossa maneira de
pensar
até agora vimos que existem regras
tintos que conseguem criar comportamento
complexo
também descobrimos que o computador
conseguimos rapidamente criar a
experimentar com estas regras brincaram
com o comportamento que será que
acontece quando juntámos todas essas
idéias usando o computador para criar
novas formas de expressão artística por
exemplo da melhor maneira eu acho que a
melhor maneira de responder esta
pergunta é fazer uma experiência e por
isso estava nos convidar para que hoje
tentarmos algo que nunca foi tentado nem
sequer sabemos se isso vai funcionar
precisa da nossa ajuda
vamos construir uma máquina interativa
quando vocês vão seus componentes
principais vai ser fácil ano temos
instruções que trabalhamos pra vocês só
de corona cruz
é termos as instruções então agora é que
vamos usar as folhas acordaram o que
este fez a 3 e eu crio vamos começar com
as folhas pousada sobre o colo não
levantava as pousadas sobre o colo o cae
e experiência
nós temos aqui um projetor ligado
apontado na seleção devem conseguir o
ponto que sai do protetor e vamos fazer
uma coisa muito simples
em certa altura a luz do projetor vai
ficar verde e muito mais brilhante
nesse momento eu gostaria que o mais
rapidamente possível a orientação cartão
e segurar sem enfrentar o taiti
durante todo o tempo em que eu estiver
brilhante quando deixar de estar
brilhante baixo exatamente o cartão é só
isto enquanto estiver verde brilhante
levantou o cartão caso contrário baixo o
cartão seja iremos o projeto
desconfortável nosso dever é algo que
faltou sensibilidade não precisa olhar
directamente se vou conseguir seguir na
mesma diferença
outro ponto importante é que o projeto
vai sinalizar a cada um de vocês
individualmente ou seja o voto sim do
lado pode não estar a ver os mesmos
sinais que vocês
portanto concentra em seguida o vosso
próprio pontos e não se preocupem com
cursos em que estão a fazer ok vamos
fazer só um pequeno teste para ver se
funciona
no entanto voltou a levantar a luz
consegue levantar
obrigado e agora os baixar boa
este mesmo só mais uma vez levantar e
baixamos muito bem estamos muito bem e
vamos mostrar o que está acontecendo não
se distraiam com as imagens que vão ver
podem apreciar as mais concentra em si
mesmo tem mesmo concentrado de conclusão
que a educação fosse uma coisa
espetacular talvez daqui
portanto posso estão preparados e vamos
tentar isso que concentra se vai
não cair
vocês conseguem perceber o que está aqui
um caminho difícil do elenco nós sabemos
o que é qualquer parecer
van gaal vai voltar uma pequena pressão
do que aconteceu eu era
isso é uma tentativa de cabeça sete
chineses não cair eu queria fazer queria
tentar algo mais ambicioso já estou no
limite o tempo mas vamos fazer isso que
é espetacular e está a acontecer é que
eu vou eu vou jogar um jogo com o cob é
sempre um jogo com vocês
portanto este que nunca foi mesmo
tentado antico que ele mesmo disse que é
possível que vai acontecer vocês vão
seguir a regra tal e qual como fizeram
tamanho só mais uma vez que acontece
são procurados então 10
ok já está nos pratos
a última taça mais uma vez que quer
mostrar não vamos tentar mais uma vez
vamos ter o que aconteceu
ok hum vez percebemos então que tentei
fazer aqui eh eh eh
estávamos a jogar um jogo de arca noé
vocês conhecem o jogo blecaute teve uma
bola que se enchia longo do ecrã e tinha
um macaco que era festa fila primeira
fila aqui e quando volto quando a
raquete a assim né
os blocos foram destruídos serei só eu
estava fazendo
no entanto a
mas o ps pensa que fez com este exemplo
quanto exemplo mostramos bem como o
computador nos deixa criar novas formas
de brincar experimentar com o
comportamento das coisas e nesta ponte
entre a regra é brincadeira que eu penso
que vamos encontrar criatividade
obrigado